I'm not going to do
a presentation on a
type of integral.
I guess if you have this in
your tool kit-- and actually
you have it beyond the exam on
this type of integral, and you
actually keep it and you retain
it, then you, I think, will
become an integration jock.
But anyway, let me show you
what I'm talking about.
So let's just remember
what the product rule
of differentiation was.
So let's say I had two
functions, let's say f of x
times g of x, and I wanted to
take the derivative of this.
f of x times g of x.
Well the chain rule just told
us that this is just the same
thing as, let's say, the
derivative of the first
function f prime of x times the
second function g of x plus now
the first function f of x times
the derivative of the
second function.
And I'll show you where I'm
going with this in a second.
Now, if we were to integrate
both sides of this equation,
because we're still doing
algebra on some levels,
anything you do to one side
of the equation, you
can do to the other.
So if we were to integrate both
sides-- well if you integrate
this side, you're taking the
integral of a derivative, you
just get back to what you took
the derivative originally of,
so this just becomes f of x
times g of x, and then we have
to integrate the right hand
side, well that just becomes--
and we're doing the indefinite
integral, kind of the
antiderivative, but we can
use this tool when we do
definite integrals as well.
So that's the integral of f
prime of x g of x dx plus
the integral of f of x
g prime of x d of x.
And now this might seem a
little bit arbitrary, and it is
a little bit arbitrary, let me
take-- well, I could take
either of these-- but let me
just take this one and move it
to this side of the equation.
So I'm going to subtract
this term from both
sides of this equation.
And so, we could say this-- so
let me change colors, because
this could get confusing-- this
term right here, we could say
that term f of x g prime of x d
of x is equal to this term--
let me switch back to the
yellow-- is equal to f of
x g of x minus this term.
Because I put it onto this
side of the equation.
So what did I just do?
It looks like I just-- well, I
am just essentially playing
with the product rule
from differentiation.
That's all I did.
And you probably wondering,
well, Sal, this is all nice
and it looks fancy, but what
good is this going to do me?
Well, what I essentially just
did is I kind of proved this--
you could call this a formula,
but I often forget it,
especially once I haven't done
it a long time, and then I
actually just reprove it to
myself just by remembering the
product rule-- but this is
called integration by parts.
And I'll show you
where this is useful.
Let's say we want to take
the indefinite integral
of x cosine of x d of x.
Well, everything we have in our
integration tool kit so far I
don't think help
us here, right?
Because we don't have a
function and its derivative, so
we can't do substitution or--
which is the same thing as the
reverse chain rule-- this
isn't a simple polynomial.
So if you encounter this when
you're doing integrals, kind of
the last tool kit-- and this is
pretty sophisticated-- is to
do integration by parts.
And so how can we use this
for integration by parts?
Well, integration by parts
tells us that if we have an
integral where we have a
function and then the
derivative of another function,
then we could use this formula
to hopefully simplify it.
So what I'm going to do-- and
you might view this as, well,
Sal, how did you
know to do this?
And I'll tell you my thought
process actually after
I show you what I did.
We always, in math in general,
you always want to simplify.
You always want to move from
something that's complicated
to something that's simpler.
So in this situation, we could
assume that x is f of x, and we
could assume that g prime of x
is cosine of x, or we could
assume the other way around.
The reason why I'm going to
assume that x is f of x, and
I'm going to assume g prime of
x is cosine of x, is because
later we want to take the
derivative of f of x.
The derivative of f of x
simplifies things a lot.
And we also want to take the
integral of g prime of x.
We want to take the
antiderivative of g prime of x.
And the antiderivative of
cosine of x is sine of x,
which is just as complicated.
It's not making it any
more complicated.
And actually, try it the other
way around, and you'll see that
if you took the antiderivative
of x, you would get something
that's more complicated.
You get x squared over 2.
So that's the intuition, and
let me just solve through it,
and hopefully it'll make
a little bit more sense.
So if I assume that f of x is
x, and g prime of x is cosine
of x, then f of x-- this yellow
term, let me write it in
yellow, just for fun-- so f of
x-- so I'm saying
that f of x is x.
So that's x.
And let's say g of x is
cosine of x, right?
I'm sorry, g prime of
x is cosine of x.
So the derivative of g
of x is cosine of x.
So what's g of x?
It was the antiderivative
of cosine of x.
So that's sine of x.
I hope you understand
what I'm saying.
This can be a little confusing.
Let me write it
separately here.
Actually, well I'm running out
of space, but I'll write it in
the corner right down here.
See, I'm saying that f of x
is x and I'm saying that
g of x is sine of x.
And the reason why I knew g of
x is sine of x is because I
said the derivative, I said g
prime of x, is cosine of x.
So you know, if the function--
if the derivative of a function
is cosine, then we know the
function itself is sine.
That's just something
you memorize.
I haven't proven it to you yet,
but it's usually in the inside
cover of your calculus book.
But let's just move forward.
And then this is minus
the integral of the
derivative of f of x.
Well what's the
derivative of f of x?
Well, we said f of
x is x, right?
So the derivative is
just 1 times g of x.
Well, I already said that
g of x is sine of x.
And I think you would agree
that we've now simplified this
a good bit, because this is
just the integral of
sine of x, right?
So this is just equal to x sine
of x-- this is just this first
term right here-- minus-- and
what's the integral
of sine of x?
Well, the derivative of-- well,
let me make it even simpler.
Well we can make this a minus,
we can make this a minus sign
of x and make this a plus.
And now it's really easy.
What's the antiderivative
of minus sine of x?
We can ignore this 1.
What's the antiderivative
of minus sine of x?
Well, yeah, it's
just cosine of x.
And we should never
forget the plus c.
So we just used the product
rule to derive this formula for
integration by parts, and in a
lot of calculus books they
do this u and v and dvd.
This is the same exact thing.
I like this more, because
it naturally makes
more sense to me.
It's easier for me to read,
and I can derive at any time,
just from the product rule.
So I don't have to
necessarily memorize it.
You might want to memorize it
for the exam, because it's
faster for when you
take the AP exam.
But when you do calculus-- it's
been about fifteen years since
I learned it-- and I just
remember integration by parts
is just really a derivation of
the product rule, and that
gets me back to the format.
I don't even have
to look it up.
And then I can use it.
So that's an introduction
to integration by parts.
In the next presentation, I
will do a bunch of examples--
well, as many as I can fit in
to ten minutes of actually
using integration by parts to
solve fairly fancy integrals.
I'll see you in the
next presentation.